[موسيقى]
تتحرك الشمس يوميا من المشرق الى المغرب
وفصليا من الشمال الى جنوب ولهذا لها
مشارق ومغارب عده فلا اقسم برب المشارق
والمغارب انا لقادرون على ان نبدل خيرا
منهم وما نحن بمسبوقين ونتيجه لهذه الحركه
فان القيم الضغطيه على وجه الارض
والمسطحات المائيه يتغير بشكل دائم فينتقل
الهواء من مكان الضغط العالي الى مكان
الضغط المنخفض بما يسمى بالرياح والقيم
الضغطيه خلال هذه الايام يكون عظيما بين
الصغرى والعظمى ولهذا هبوب الرياح المثيره
للغبار والاتربه والسابقه للحالات المطريه
يكون عاصفا كان هبوب الريح من نحو ارضكم
يثير فتات المسك والعنبر النده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وتنقسم الرياح الى قسمين رياح دائمه وهي
ذات الهبوب الدائم من جهه معينه ورياح
عابره وهي ذات الهبوب العابر الى جهه
معينه وامهات الرياح عند العرب اربعه
الشماليه وهي للروح والنسيم الجنوبيه وهي
للامطار والانواء والصبا وهي لالقاح
الاشجار والسحاب والدبور وهي ريح العذاب
والدمار الا يا هبوب الريح بلغ رسالتي
سليمه وعرض بي كانك
مازح
[موسيقى]